[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's black history month yay every
morning this month i wake up and look to
see what's waiting for me under the
tubman tree will it be a white person
telling me what martin luther king would
have wanted or better yet someone saying
why do we need a black history month how
would you like it if we had a white
history month you might be thinking
that's crazy the only reason we know
about such notable white achievements as
betsy ross's apparently groundbreaking
ability to use a needle and thread or
paul revere's remarkable ability to
scream and ride a horse at the same time
is because every month is white history
month but hear me out
i think we do need a white history month
because the american history that's
taught in schools is so whitewashed we
don't learn the real story we learn lies
like george washington chopping down a
cherry tree but not the fact that george
had 18 slaves before he turned 18.
18 slaves when i was 18 i didn't have 18
shirts i had three shirts and they all
looked like this
each one of them cuter than the last
we learned that abraham lincoln said
four score and seven years ago but not
that he said i am not nor ever have been
in favor of bringing about in any way
the social and political equality of the
black and white races there must be the
position of superior and inferior and i
am in favor of having the superior
position assigned to the white race
they don't put that on the penny
partially because it would make the
penny too long and partly because our
schools don't teach an honest version of
american history and that's why we need
white history month history shouldn't
just be a list of names and dates it's
supposed to give us context for the
present how can we learn about harriet
tubman and frederick douglass and mlk's
response to inequality without
understanding the true history of the
country that enshrined that inequality
into law
for example in regular history they tell
you the second amendment was created to
protect against tyranny but during white
history month you would learn the truth
that the right to bear arms was added to
the constitution so white men could keep
their slaves in check
that is a true fact see how much we're
learning white history month is fun i
hope you're taking notes in your white
history month trapper
get up and keeper yay it's martin luther
king day
it's a day we look upon with happiness
and cheer get up and shout yay it's
martin luther king day
it's the day we remember what he was
fighting for
a bunch of laws were made to keep black
people oppressed so black people
organized to try to clean this mess so
mlk said hey america we want civil
rights and they said maybe just not as
much as whites a lot of white people got
upset that we even dared to ask and
that's the really crazy part so let's
spend some time there they hated black
people so bad they couldn't sit next to
them on a bus and they didn't just go
away they're still alive and voting like
people always look at the civil rights
movement as like this little bit of time
but it lasted forever
and it's still kind of going on
in theaters this spring
you've heard of harriet tubman's bravery
the way we're getting treated here will
not stand her courage
and i have a plan to get out
i'm gonna escape this plantation her
fearlessness
and then i'm gonna come back for all of
you finally a film that tells the truth
about what drove her to greatness and
i'll tell you why i'm coming back for
you because i have a dream to see black
people free no to end inequality not
quite to destroy the economic system
that relies on our enslavement for other
people's profit
no nothing like that what is it then to
be on
the 20
bill
harriet's dream the true story of what
motivated one of the greatest women in
history
[Music]
i can't run anymore yes you can go on
without me no
i'm taking you north so you can have a
wonderful life so you can get married
and have children who have children who
have children who have children and then
those children
those children will be free no those
children will see my face on the 20 bill
[Music]
the true story of her personal life
harriet you don't have to keep going
back for them you've done enough enough
to be on the five maybe or the 10
but
not enough to be on the 20.
what and the true story of her legacy
[Music]
miss tubman
i owe you everything
i'll honor your memory by working every
day of my life to end our oppression or
could you get my face on the 20.
i don't see how it's easy i made a
prototype
you see it
coming this february it's the story of
an icon
follow me to freedom yeah
and when we get there
let's change the way money looks
come on
come on guys
harriet's dream
why have real change when you can have a
symbol
on a piece of paper
in the past few weeks several state
legislatures have introduced bills
banning critical race theory they've
done it in georgia tennessee florida
mississippi oklahoma and a bunch of
other states where you can buy
confederate flags at gas stations but
the thing is while some americans are
furious about critical race theory a lot
of people don't even know what it is and
i don't blame them critical race theory
sounds like the subtitle of a book
called mario kart for dummies first i'm
going to pick up speed then i'm going to
throw some nana's then i'm going to get
some coins and that is my critical race
theory now in order to talk about
critical race theory we're going to
start with something called the 1619
project the 1619 project is an
extraordinary pulitzer prize winning
work of journalism conceived of by a
reporter named nicole hannah jones
it was released to commemorate the 400th
anniversary of the arrival of enslaved
africans in the colonies that would
become america that's right the first
anniversary is paper the fifth is wood
and the 400th is well researched and
award-winning journalism get to work
husbands
one of the reasons the 1619 project has
been so controversial is that it
proposes that we should talk a lot more
about the consequences of slavery and
the contributions of black people when
we talk about the foundations of our
country which of course means
acknowledging that racism permeates our
history because the fact is right now
kids aren't learning the realities of
our history in 2018 only 8 percent of
u.s high school seniors could identify
slavery as the central cause of the
civil war and that is horrifying that's
like only eight percent of kids knowing
you can make a volcano with mentos and
diet coke they're both basic facts now
the good news is that about two-thirds
of students do seem to know that the
emancipation proclamation freed the
slaves except and here's the thing it
absolutely did not do that that required
a whole constitutional amendment which
wasn't even ratified till after abraham
lincoln died
in a horrible boating accident
all the 1619 project was supposed to do
is help teach students about the role
slavery has played in american history
now some people claim that's rewriting
history and maybe it is but shouldn't we
revise things when we get better
information we used to prescribe cocaine
for two things now we know better and
it's mostly used so that former lacrosse
players can talk about crypto for seven
hours straight
yeah you gotta have bitcoin bro
the point is as we learn more of course
we should adjust what we're teaching in
some parts of the country if students
learn black history at all they learn
that
most masters treated their slaves kindly
or slaves were given the opportunity to
become christians instead of remaining
heathen or that slaves got to eat all
the barbecue pringles they wanted
all of those things are equal parts
[ __ ] but the first two are actual
quotes from a textbook that was used in
south carolina for 130 years which is
probably why their current senator
thinks that racism doesn't exist he
thinks it disappeared right around when
daniel boone killed all the dinosaurs
now this would be a great time for me to
tell you what we need to do to improve
our national history curriculum but
here's the thing we don't have a
national history curriculum
every state sets its own teaching
standards think of school curriculums
like state mottos every state has a
different one and some of them are
batshit crazy oregon's state motto is
she flies with her own wings
that's not a motto that's a tagline for
a cicada biopic
the fact is most states don't mandate a
specific amount of black history at all
which is why most white people only know
about harriet tubman martin luther king
and barack obama
even worse 20 of them think that that's
destiny's child
if only there were some kind of say
prize-winning black history curriculum
developed by some of the greatest
scholars in the country i'm sure that
americans would welcome it with open
arms and by arms i mean guns because it
turns out there are a lot of white
people who really don't want to learn
the truth about america and that finally
brings us back to critical race theory
which is just a way of examining society
and history without pretending that
racism doesn't exist racism is part of
our past and our present it's been with
us for 400 years you can't squash it
into two sentences in a textbook between
the civil war and the roaring twenties
you shouldn't fix history to make you
feel better learning about slavery feels
awful too bad try living with its
repercussions while white people tell
you there weren't any also it should
make you feel bad it should make you
feel so bad that you make sure nothing
like it ever happens again
critical race theory gives us the tools
to examine our history in an open and
honest way and to fix the parts of our
educational system that aren't doing
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you